пекарня в центрі Берліна робота тут
кипить з ночі адже вже з 6 години ранку
перед цим традиційним німецьким закладом
збирається черга за смаколиками та
гарячою кавою Саме тут знайшли роботу
пара українців які мусили залишити рідну
Одесу одразу після повномасштабного
вторгнення Росії Тетяна та Ігор як і
більшість українців Вони спробували
звернутися за соціальною допомогою від
німецької держави та зізнаються майже
одразу зрозуміли що хочуть вставати на
ноги самі Та не отримувати соц допомогу
вирішили шукатимуть роботу та
платитимуть податки у ФРН
я архітекторка За освітою але на пенсії
ми приїхали зіткнулися з соціальними
службами це важко давалося сидіти в
черзі без Мови тоді ще не так
налагоджено було систему не так легко
треба було стояти в черзі чекати коли
все вирішиться а потім колись отримати
гроші ми вирішили що ми підемо працювати
саме в цей час пекарня Zibert більш ніж
120-річною історією шукала працівників
Ми шукали людей ігор відгукнувся у нас
було таке гарне Відчуття і ми сказали
давайте просто подивимось їм все
вдавалося дуже добре самого початку я
насправді був задоволений ними
[музика]
наразі Тетяна вже закінчила
інтеграційний курс до вимушеного
переїзду пара не знала німецьку мову
досвіду випіканні смаколиків вони також
не мали обидва українці працювали раніше
архітекторами Утім це не завадило їм
швидко опанувати нову професію навіть
без знання мови
без лінієчки никак вони дивляться Вони
працюють знають що ми робимо ми
показуємо у Ігоря іноді є телефон з
перекладачем Тетяна вже навчилася
непогано Іноді вона розмовляє
англійською але також і німецькою тому
що хоче вивчити німецьку теж Насправді
все йде чудово
робота складна але Ігор та Тетяна
працюють із задоволенням
дефектів
Ми никогда не думали Ми ніколи не думали
що потрапимо у таку сімейну обстановку
коли ми як удома Це просто не передати
кажуть що робота із тістом і в колективі
дозволяє відволіктися від новин з Рідної
Одеси
виїхали ми как бы заработки пропали и
нужно было виїхали Ми через те що
заробітки зникли треба було щось їсти Та
якось жити Оскільки ми не сидимо на
дивані та не скаржимося одразу
влаштувалися на роботу
сложно несложно
якщо руки не місці то звичайно навчитися
можна всьо
витримка бажання за хорошу працю добре
платять
традиционные немецкие це я зараз роблю
дішнеке по нашому це равлики роблю масло
самай яблука готую натуральні отримують
тісто яке теж готується натурально
щодня в мене 3-4 пироги виходить 3-4
пирога працювати старанно для Ігоря та
Тетяни вкрай важливо адже вони не хочуть
аби про українців думали погано знаєте
как що знаєте якщо нас брали Як
українців і без часу в голові персонацію
представляєш як думати про те які
українці
ми працюємо як совість дозволяє
совість позволяє так само як Тетяна та
Ігор деякі українці Які опинилися в
Німеччині після вторгнення Росії також
змогли знайти роботу протягом 2022 року
в Німеччині на 65 тисяч збільшилась
кількість українців які сплачують
соціальні внески із зарплати у
федеральному агентстві зайнятості
очікують на зростання цієї кількості
крім того ще 21 тисяча українців мають
міні -джол тобто роботу у Німеччині з
оплатою не більше 520 євро на місяць з
яких зазвичай не сплачується соціальні
відрахування
інтеграційні та мовні курси в Німеччині
відвідуються краще ніж будь-коли раніше
саме завдяки такій підготовці яку надає
ФРН змогла знайти роботу і Галина
Корнієнко
разом з дружиною двома котами та двома
собаками вона змусила була виїхати з
гостомеля перші дні Вторгнення в Україні
жінка працювала в громадських
організаціях з фокусом на допомогу
жінкам зразливих рук роботу жінці
вдалося знайти за фахом зараз в Берліні
Галину консультує українських жінок щодо
жіночого здоров'я в німецькій
громадській організації
коли ми самоорганізувалися ми почали
зав'язувати з різні зв'язки з німецькими
ЛГБТ організаціями організаціями
жіночими організаціями феміністичними
організаціями і так ми познайомились з
фамилистями центр вони залучили Гранд
грантові гроші на підтримку українських
жінок на консультування стосовно
жіночого здоров'я для українських жінок
і в них з'явилося дві вакансії причому
це було їх
свідоме рішення що Ці дві вакансії
повинні зайняти Українки Галина працює
вже майже місяць і хоча роботу вдалося
знайти через власні соціальні зв'язки
навички працевлаштування і подачі резюме
в Німеччині вона отримала під час
підготовчих курсів
я на обліку в джобцентрі завдяки
joe-центру я брала Джокович тобто
консультування саме як в Німеччині
влаштована система працевлаштування яким
чином Тут подають резюме як цей резюме
правильно складати як складати
мотиваційний лист ось пройшла цей
коучинг і так якось сталося воно
співпало в мене якраз закінчився коучинг
в мене були вже всі документи готові і
тут в організації яку я знала з'явилася
ця вакансія
Українка вивчила німецьку до рівня B2
Галина порівнює свій попередній досвід з
тим що мала вдома і каже звикла
присвячувати роботі більше часу
це перший раз в моєму житті коли я
працюю на півставки
в Україні зазвичай в мене було
Останній раз коли я виїжджала в мене
було 6 проектів і там не
нерегулювався робочий день тобто я сама
його собі регулювала і тут Для мене це
дуже дивно оце робота Залишаємо на
роботі Коли я намагаюся підгризти там
Документи додому попрацювати директорка
каже нє вдома треба відпочивати роботу
Залишаємо на роботі українці шукають
роботу в Німеччині На тлі складної
ситуації на робочому ринку в країні у
ФРН нестача кваліфікованих кадрів
сягнула рекордного рівня попри нинішній
порівняно низькі темпи розвитку
економіки за даними інституту німецької
економіки торік у Німеччині через
відсутність відповідних кандидатів серед
безробітних вакантними залишалися понад
630 тисяч робочих місць це пікове
значення за весь час спостережень від
2010 року через те що покоління
бебі-бумерів виходить на пенсію наш
ринок праці просто сильно скоротиться і
тоді нам потрібна імміграція щорічно
Німеччина потребує близько 400 тисяч і
мігрантів і ми маємо подбати про те щоб
зробити Німеччину більш привабливою
в Німеччині активно розробляють так
звану картку можливостей яку зможуть
отримувати іноземні працівники новий
документ має спростити вимоги до
іноземців але є проблеми які необхідно
вирішити якщо Німеччина хоче залучити
іноземних працівників і створити такі
умови щоб вони залишились і працювали в
країні нещодавно Німеччина назвали
найгіршою країною у світі для емігрантів
коли мова йде про такі важливі речі як
пошук житла вивчення мови та цифрові
послуги чи можуть українці які вже тут
розв'язати проблему з нестачею фахівців
у Німеччині
Ні це досить ілюзорно в Німеччині
потрібні майже 2 мільйони працівників
якщо ми просто порахуємо це досить
простий аналіз до Німеччини приїхало
близько мільйона людей з них близько 40%
діти це означає що мова йде про близько
600 тисяч тут є момент не всі хочуть
залишатися тут у Німеччині наші
результати показують що залишатися хоче
лише кожен третій тобто з 600 тисяч лише
200 тисяч могли б довгостроково
інтегруватися на ринку праці тож Якщо
порівняти 200 тисяч і 2 мільйони попиту
то ми побачимо що українці не можуть
стати розв'язанням проблеми нестачі рук
навіть ті Українці які хотіли б
працевлаштуватися і лишитися В Німеччині
стикаються з проблемами у питаннях мови
та визнання кваліфікації
кілька перешкод для інтеграції
українських біженців на ринок праці
передумови дуже хороші є ступені та
необхідні кваліфікації але людям ще
треба вивчити мову існують проблеми з
визнанням дипломів і відсутністю догляду
за дітьми особливо для жінок
здолати ці перешкоди поки вдалося не
всім дослідження показує що однією з
причин сповільненого пошуку роботи є
невизначеність яку несе з собою війна
адже багато хто планує повернутися
додому після закінчення бойових дій
поки цього не сталося сидіти на місці
Тетяна з Ігорем не планують і кажуть що
часу Німеччині можна використати з
користю
робочий день закінчився Іноді я дуже
радісно посміхаюся що деякі люди лише в
цей час прокидаються а я вийшовши на
вулицю від цього відчуває такий Прилив
сил що зробила справу вже Ось стоїть
черга і люди їдять те що я робила коли
дуже важко я говорю чоловікові я більше
не можу я їду до Одеси додому я
втомилася вихідних
він каже почекаємо до кінця вихідних і
ти мені скажеш це звичайно вистачає
кінцевих щоб знову йти працювати але те
що важко я не приховую важко всім
працювати важко завжди
Утім робота хоч і виснажлива надихає
пару продовжувати
Ми цілий год
Ми цілий рік жодного дня не пропустили
удосконалюємося дуже багато чого
навчилися і Ігор і я Мені дуже
подобається коли Ігор каже я себе таким
кволем старим відчував Я не міг підняти
нагору під носа зараз я лівою однією
закидаю тобто ця дисципліна активність
надали нам і витривалості і фізичного
розвитку
повернемося ми нові оновлені різні ми ж
скоріше піднімемо те що зруйновано
[музика]